mais mais sérieux comment tu fais ça
[ __ ] non c'est bon ça saoule c'est bon
j'en ai marre non franchement tu fais le
mal Stre Fighter tu vas voir maintenant
je vais sortir combat tu vas me
rigoler
non Stargate non
Ultraman non même pas en
[Musique]
rêve blazingy non
tu essayer non non
merciter bon je crois que j'ai pas le
choix bon déjà va falloir que je fasse
un petit cours d'histoire parce que en
France Ultraman c'est un héros qui est
presque totalement inconnu la série N
été diffé que très partiellement sur M6
au club de Ré avant d'être retiré al à
quoi ça ressemblait ben en fait c'est
très simple un super méchant arrive dans
un costume en carton il est super vénère
il veut détruire la Terre Ultraman
arrive lui casse la gueule avec son
rayon laser et puis après tout le monde
chante sur une musique japonaise devant
le soleil couchant et voilà c'est
magnifique d'ailleurs la série est plus
ou moins à l'origine des déclinaisons
qui donneront les Super Sentai comme
Bioman ou XOR ultraan quant à lui est
resté vraiment populaire au Japon hein
puisque la série a été créée en 1966 et
pourtant on continue aujourd'hui encore
à en faire des suites et des jeux vidéos
le jeu super nest lui est sorti en 1991
ce jeu étaé réputé tellement pourri
qu'il avait été massacré dans tous les
magazines à sa sortie on va bien voir
s'il est à la hauteur de sa
réputation trois niveaux de difficulté
qui en fait correspondent à trois
niveaux de sadisme mais j'y reviendrai
plus tard et tiens au passage le premier
truc pour afficher le menu option qui
est caché il faut appuyer sur Start et
select en même temps
pourquoi mais pourquoi pourquoi devoir
faire une combinaison bizarre pour
afficher un truc aussi simple que les
options c'est trop dur de marquer option
tout simplement la série quand même
somom du Kid je me demande comment ils
sont débrouillés pour améliorer ça en
jeu vidéo
ouais non bon ok j'ai rien dit en
fait gudis 120000 tonnes et ben [ __ ]
mon cochon ça fait 12 fois la Tour
[Musique]
Effel un bouton pour le pied un bouton
pour le point un pour le laser et c'est
tout voilà voilà le jeu ultran trois
boutons unique rien de plus ce jeu est
nul ce jeu ne mérite même pas
l'appellation de jeu c'est la base des
jeux de baston c'est quand même les
combinaisons de coup là il y a rien il
il y a trois boutons c'est tout là
franchement ça a été codé par des gens
qui en avaient mais rien à [ __ ] le
bouton pour le point ne sert quasiment
jamais car sa poré est trop petite donc
ben la seule solution c'est d'avvancer
en N des coups de pied
voilà voilà absolument génial là il est
bon pour le Moulin Rouge
[Musique]
bah allez quand même je suis mauvaise
langue il y a d'autres coups il y a un
hercut qui en fait j'ai aucune idée de
son utilité vu qu'il a une portée encore
plus faible que le coup de point et il y
a un coup de pied retourné bon c'est le
trème jeu de bandaille que je teste ok
bon ils ont fait des bons jeux c'est sûr
il y a pas mal de choses de ce qui
arrive en Europe du Japon c'est grâce à
eux ok mais ils avaient aussi une
fâcheuse tendance à pourrir
lamentablement les licences pour en
faire des merdes à l'arrache juste pour
en récolter le
pogon allez voilà c'est génial j'aurais
plus de fun à mat l'intégral de Deric
plutôt qu'à jouer à ce jeu
ok
finish e mais
oh oh il est bugé ou quoi
ok attends on va essayer des
combinaisons de boutons non non non plus
[ __ ] mais attends faut faire une
combinaison les on à la Mortal Kombat ou
quoi non mais [ __ ] mais qu CR mais
c'est quoi ce plan
là
ah non mais en plus il régène de la
vie [ __ ] mais oh non mais sans
déconner
[Musique]
[ __ ] en fait vous voyez le machin en
bas là c'est le système de laser il y a
quatre niveaux de puissance qu'on
contrôle avec L1 et R1 et il faut
utiliser le 4è niveau sur le boss quand
il est en finish votre barre de
puissance monte toute seule donc si vous
venez d'utiliser la meilleure chose à
faire bah c'est de
s'enfuir c'est tendu quand même le mec
il est tellement rigide quand il tape on
dirait qu'il a aval un lampadaire mais
quand il s'agit sfire on dirait un
acrobate
chinois voilà boss fini stage
suivant bon vous vous rappelez au début
j'avais parlé des trois niveaux de
difficulté bah alors pour faire un
amalgame on a tous un pote normalement
Fighter qui joue comme
[Musique]
ça pas comme toi en fait ben en fait
c'est pareil le niveau de difficulté
sert juste à définir le degré de spamage
idiot des rayons laser et sérieusement
c'est sérieusement c'est je peux même
pas je peux même pas approcher je ne
peux même pas approcher [ __ ] mais
laisse-moi jouer enfin quoi toute cette
zone là devant lui là c'est la mort dès
que vous vous approchez le Scrib lui
fait faire automatiquement un laser et
même si vous êtes au taqu sur les
réflexes vous vous faites chouper quand
même deux fois sur trois et c'est même
pas la peine d'essayer d'attaquer
l'ennemi par le haut dès que vous
touchez l'ennemi au corps à corps [ __ ]
vous prenez un coup ou quoi mais comme
ça sans rien faire il y a aucune raison
comme ça il suffit d'être à côté pour
prendre un coup même si lui ne tape pas
mais regardez je je ne peux même pas
placer une attaque je peux même pas le
toucher j'arrive même pas à m'approcher
allez sérieux il y a des jeux fait par
des nuls des incompétent et des clous là
ce jeu il cumule les trois c'est
impossible ça fait seulement 10 minutes
que j'y jou 10 minutes de ma vie caché
partir fumer j'en ai assez ça suffit
[Musique]
vous connaissez la loi des séries la loi
de l'emmerdement maximum si vous pensiez
que quelque chose pouvait pas être pire
et ben si ça peut toujours être pire
rise of the robot un jeu sorti en 1994
un jeu qui était super attendu parce que
les captures d'écran faisaient baver
tout le monde et aussi accessoirement
parce que la musique du jeu était
composée par Bran may le guitariste de
Queen le jeu quant à lui a été diffusé
sur la majorité des plateformes de
l'époque
[Musique]
bon alors ça pour l'époque c'était beau
he les cinématiques étaient quand même
plutôt
sympa mais c'est là que les choses se
gâent parce que le jeu est mauvais mais
mauvais mais un point c'est c'est un
scandale ce jeu est sorti 2 ans après
Street Fighter mais au niveau des
contrôles on revient mais 15 ans en
arrière la megga Drive est comme
d'habitude la version la moins gâtée les
trois boutons A B et C servent à taper
plus plus ou moins fort mais pour passer
des coups de pied au coup de point il
faut appuyer sur START il faut appuyer
en plein combat sur Start pour switcher
de coup start c'est le bouton pause
depuis qu'il existe un bouton Start sur
les manettes ça a toujours été la pause
alors pourquoi ils ont fait ça c'est
totalement logique et en plus du coup il
y a plus de pause sur le jeu si vous
voulez vous lever pour aller pisser en
plein combat mais vous pouvez pas vous
êtes obligés de rester là et finir et
vous pissz dessus voilà la difficulté
est totalement stupide certains des
robots vous pulvérisent en deux coups
alors que des fois ils vous tape sans
même vous
touchez et en plus l'animation mais
c'est la même pour tous les coups
regardez ça ça c'est un coup faible ça
c'est un coup moyen et ça c'est un coup
fort [ __ ] mais il y a aucune
différence entre les trois il y a deux
prises mais elles sont totalement
irréalisables encore sur Ultraman ça va
C facile de sortir un hpercute ou de
faire une projection mais là c'est
infaisable c'est censé être au bas plus
un bouton mais [ __ ] j'y arrive pas
mais ça me rend fou quoi il l'autre
connard de robot qui me colle dans le
COI B ses cou comme un idiot [ __ ]
allez [ __ ] de merde lâche-moi fou le C
[ __ ] mais c'est une blague c'est un f
la combinis ça existe pas j'en suis sûr
ils ont mis ça pour que les gens se
rendent fou essayer de faire un truc
infaisable la description sur la boîte
est à hurler de rire il ne tient qu'à
vous de mat la révolution des robots au
passage le nombre des persos est on a
incroyable de 6 c'est juste pathétique
préparez-vous pour une jouabilité
exceptionnelle une intelligence
artificiel brutale et des graphismes en
3D révolutionnaires qui vous feront
regarder d'un notre œil tous les jeux de
baston là là c'est clair que quand tu as
joué à rise of the robot tu regardes le
monde d'un notre œil parce que tout a
l'air mieux à côté de ça même ultran
c'est un bon jeu à côté de ce truc allez
[ __ ] faut pas déconner sérieusement je
suis pas quelqu'un de cruel mais
prenez-le essayez-le un peu sur
émulateur même si vous voulez mais pour
tester vraiment ce que c'est un vrai
mauvais jeu [ __ ] franchement après
rise of de robot je crois qu'on a touché
le fond des habis quoi on peut pas
descendre plus bas
ah non oh non [ __ ]
non oh non
[ __ ]
hein qu'est-ce qui se passe mais je suis
qui ah non mais je je comprends rien je
comprends pas c'est quoi ces chiffres là
sérieux pourquoi j'ai pas de barre de
vie c'est quoi cette animation c'est
saccadé à mort [ __ ] ils font n'importe
quoi non j'en peux plus [ __ ] j'en peux
plus je comprends pas le jeu oh non
[ __ ] non ça recommence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ta V ASA
bien
[Musique]